[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue d'un point de vue
bienvenue à vous tous qui nous suivaient
sur le site du figaro et sur la page
facebook
posez vos questions faites nous part de
vos commentaires c'est parti pour 50
minutes de débat débat où il sera
question de la catalogne le feuilleton
catalan qui s'est aujourd'hui déplacée à
bruxelles ou par la puce damon a donné
une conférence de presse avec des
annonces importantes on va en débattre
on parlera aussi la fin de l'état
d'urgence car dès demain c'est la
nouvelle loi antiterroriste qui
s'applique
un texte qu emmanuel macron est allé
défendre devant la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme à strasbourg ce soir
enfin sauf rebondissement de dernière
minute les cinq ministres et
responsables constructif devrait être
exclus de leur parti d'origine les
républicains le bureau politique de l
air se réunit dans moins d'une heure
mais déjà une autre polémique surgie
quelle forme doit prendre le débat entre
les candidats à la présidence du
mouvement
enfin on parlera des états unis et des
soupçons d'ingérence russe sur la
campagne présidentielle
la menace se précise pour donald trump
même si le dossier reste bien compliqué
merci à 24 dec là pour en débattre le 6
juin
bonjour 1 vous coprésidé la fondation
verte européenne est conseillère
municipale à vanves dans les
hauts-de-seine avant l'écologie vous
étiez au parti socialiste
vous êtes aussi l'auteur de la france
résiste tel à l'écologie c'est paru en
2006 en 2016 des éditions le bord de
l'eau merci d'être régulièrement sur ce
plateau de point de vue merci à vous
aussi adélaïde zulfikarpasic directrice
de bba opinion qui nous fait également
le plaisir d'être régulièrement parmi
nous bonjour andré bercoff un jour
écrivain journaliste vous animer une
émission quotidienne sur sud radio
votre dernier livre paru en 2016
schaeffer s'intitule donald trump les
raisons de la colère et nous avons eu le
plaisir d'accueillir frédéric météo
cette chef du service politique de
france inter après trop de passer par
france culture bienvenus leur seul
espoir alors il fallait s'accrocher pour
comprendre car les couches damon pendant
sa conférence de presse à bruxelles
en tout début d'après-midi un sabir
franco catalo anglais d'où il ressort
qu'ils pointent numéro 1 le leader
catalan n'est pas en belgique pour
demander l'asile politique mais ils sont
quand même ça
allez en à bruxelles en exil avec quatre
de ses ministres
point numéro 2 les indépendantistes
participeront aux élections de décembre
prochain
on écoute kyle busch damon c'était à la
mi journée à bruxelles à l'action de la
justice ne vais pas on veut pas négliger
notre responsabilité face à la justice à
la communauté nationale et de percu
clairement à l'europe
je lui demande de réagir je lui demande
de réagir
nous on va respecter le résultat de
l'élection que sont convoqués par le 21
décembre comme comment nous ont contrés
toujours il importe ce qu'il était les
résultats il fait l'effort louable de
parler en français car ce que demandait
le cycle mythe c'est la mascarade qui
continue c'est un coup politique de sa
part moi je trouve que il a trouvé la
seule porte de sortie qu'il était
possible que s'il était resté à
barcelone il était coincé par rapport à
tout ce qui avait été dit sur le
caractère illégal du référendum et puis
il était aux mains de rajoy et il
courait le risque de l'emprisonnement et
là il a il a fait un coup qui est
intéressant parce que depuis le début
en fait ils interpellent l'europe en
disant vous n'avez plus le droit de vous
considérer comme un politique et vous
devez d'une manière ou d'une autre à
monter une nouvelle manière d'intervenir
sur ce genre de conflits qui est en fait
un conflit une difficulté des états
nation exister et c'est donc je ne dis
pas qu'il a retrouvé la puissance mais
je pense qu'ils s'en est sortie
relativement et puis il ya une ambiance
très bruxelloise dans ce que vous venez
de dire sans cette conférence de presse
parce que quand on est à bruxelles de
toute façon c'est toujours le sabir
c'est à dire que de toute façon on parle
anglais français espagnol etc
ça fait partie de la vie bruxelloise en
tout cas pas forcément l'avis belge met
la vie des institutions européennes donc
en ce sens il ya un côté un petit peu
tintin dans son dans son discours
politique mais moi il ya quelque chose
une sorte de sympathie que j'éprouvais
pas quand il était à barcelone il a
réussi sans couronne robert et moi je ne
partage pas vraiment
à votre opinion la sympathie je pensais
que cette personne aurait au moins soit
le courage de rester à barcelone et de
risque et si les risques et c'est à dire
d'aller jusqu'au bout de deux sacs de sa
conviction intime en artiste soit de
faire sans comparer à de gaulle à
londres
enfin il aurait pu vraiment adopter une
posture là qu'est ce qu'il dit nous
allons respecter les institutions nous
allons respecter rajoy
et puis l'europe joue son jeu mais
attendez vous savez trés trés bien
l'europe ne peut être que vent debout
devant carlos puis je démonte pas ce que
demain il y aura le risque d'implosion
centrifuge et de toute l'europe
à partir du moment où ils acceptent
l'europe l'indépendance de la catalogne
vous savez très bien ce qui peut se
passer au pays basque en bretagne ou
ailleurs
donc l'europe est vent debout contre ça
je dis pas qu'ils ont raison ou tort
âgées pas de jugement de valeur mais
pour le moment je trouve que la position
de carlos puis-je demont est une
position
elle est tristement social démocrate il
s'est affaibli de toute façon il était
déjà affaibli donc il n'est pas plus
faible depuis cette conférence de presse
moi je pense plutôt qui reprend un peu
d'air c'est à dire que à barcelone il
était coincé avec d'un côté l'état
central espagnol
rajoy et une base parfois extrêmement
radicaliser avec des partis
indépendantistes de gauche radicale ou
d'extrême gauche qui pouvait lui mettre
la pression donc ils étaient entre le
marteau et l'enclume
il fallait qu'ils reprennent un peu
d'air c'est la première chose deuxième
chose il annonce importante du jour
c'est qu'il dit qu'il respectera le
résultat des élections l'essentiel des
partis catalans la majorité des partis
actuellement présent parlement catalan
vont participer à ces élections dont au
moins il ya un processus politique
ensuite sur la question de l'europe
c'est pas tant l'europe l'union
européenne en tant que telle elle n'a
pas son mot à dire sur une indépendance
c'est chaque état qui peut répondre
effectivement on sait que les états
européens dans leur ensemble dans leur
totalité ne reconnaîtront pas
l'indépendance mais en appeler à l'union
européenne sur ce genre de choses si on
appelait à personne il y aura diplomatie
européenne du rôle de l'union européenne
et de pour le moment l'absence de nom
les dias ion le nom rôle de we had élite
vous avez regardé un petit peu
l'évolution de l'opinion espagnole sur
ce sujet depuis les semaines passées et
ça valide effectivement l'analyse de
métaux sur le fait qu'avant cette
conférence de presse il apparaissait
déjà affaiblis puisque il ya un sondage
qui est défié par el mundo dimanche
dernier donc le 29 octobre et qui
montrent que le bloc indépendantistes
dans l'hypothèse d'élections serait en
recul assez nette de 5 points dans
l'opinion alors que les partis
traditionnels constitution espagnole
espagnol et y compris en catalogne alors
qu'au contraire les partis traditionnels
sur un progression et du coup ferait jeu
égal
ça montre bien que cette séquence a
laissé des traces dans l'opinion
publique à la fois espagnol en catalogne
et puis on pourra peut-être en parler
mais en europe plus globalement et en
france alors je me disais la non
médiation européenne parce que c'est
vrai et il a déjà demandé et pour le
moment c'est on lui ferme la porte au
nez sur sur ce chapitre
lussier schmidt il risque encore de se
prendre une fin de non recevoir
non mais je crois que on voit bien qu
actuellement effectivement dans l'état
des institutions européennes il n'est
pas question de soutenir puis deux mots
etc
moi ce que je dis simplement c'est que
l'europe fait face à des problèmes qui
sont inédits et que la catalogue c'est
pas le seul le seul sujet sur lequel
l'europe d'une certaine manière doit
peut-être et jeu par les institutions
européennes de l'union européenne
imaginez d'avoir à l'avenir un
questionnement sur des choses par
exemple les causses il ya là les
questions qui sont posées en italie il
ya une crise des états nations et quand
on veut une europe fédérale il faut se
poser la question un moment
nous de savoir si on veut jouer un rôle
politique ou pas ça signifie de la
médiation ne sais pas du tout ce que
puigdemont depuis dont voulait prendre
en otage d'une certaine manière les
institutions européennes pour avoir une
espèce d'échappatoire par rapport à son
son duo avec rajoy
c'est parce que je ne dis pas qu'il
fallait accéder aux demandes depuis que
demont mais ce que je dis c'est que s'il
n'y a pas une discussion politique entre
les chefs d'état sur ce genre de choses
est seulement une volonté de dire on
n'interviendra pas c'est que le wrp
reste un nain politique et on ne pourra
pas porter l'espoir européen
si l'europe n'interviendra quand il ya
des crises très d'eric météo je vous
donnerai un site après effectivement il
ya des gosses il ya le nord de l'italie
il ya la flandre qui il ya déjà des
moments très forts il ya eu le pays
basque qui était un mouvement encore
d'une autre d'une autre nature l'aller
les mouvements les plus récents dont on
parle sont aussi des mouvements de
régions riches
les flamands pour faire simple ils
estiment qu'ils en ont assez de payer
pour les wallons les italiens du nord
ils ont en marre de payer pour ceux du
mezzogiorno l'ecosse elle pourrait être
prospère parce qu'elle est assise sur
les gisements de gaz et de pétrole
catalogne et la catalogne effectivement
à barcelone qui est une place financière
importante est par ailleurs se susurre
l'europe je pense aussi que l'union
européenne a un peu joué avec le feu par
principe quasiment par nature une europe
fédérale est une europe qui fait mal aux
états nations
parce que c'est c'est antinomique l'état
nation et la construction de l'europe
fédérale et l'europe l'union européenne
pendant des années à jouer en quelque
sorte les régions pour ceux qui
connaissent le quartier des institutions
européennes à bruxelles un immense
bâtiment qui est peut-être aussi grands
que ceux de la commission qui est celui
du comité des régions où les régions les
collectivités locales à bruxelles sont
ont pignon sur rue sont considérés comme
des institutions en tant que tel en leur
donnant cette puissance en leur donnant
cet affichage en l'ordonnant les fonds
structurels qui permet de développer
région par région l'europe a aussi aidé
à développer les régions qu'il a semé
européen fédéralisme européen égale
fédéralisme nationaux
ça c'est formidable c'est votre
information est importante parce que
j'aimerais qu'on l'oubli et c'est vrai
que c'est le formidable hypocrisie
quelque part de l'union européenne vers
le jouant sur les deux tableaux par
rapport à d'un côté le régionalisme et
d'un côté l'europe fédérale qui n'existe
pas sur yon clair l'europe se comportent
mieux au fédéral mais ne l'est pas du
tout et moi ce qui me gêne vraiment
l'attitude puis je dépensais l'attitude
des politiques
aujourd'hui on attend d'un politique
plus jamais être plus que jamais c'est à
dire que à partir du moment où il était
lui à fond pour l'un des bars ce qu'on
vous dit que les principes d'un parti
indépendantiste dû mettre la pression
mais il était quoi puis-je de mots il
était indépendante et il était
complètement indépendante je suis
d'accord mais enfin on va jusqu'au bout
d'une certaine logique là il dit écoutez
moi je vers l'europe effectivement
j'attends toute l'europe alors j'espère
que vous allez bouger mais on va
respecter les institutions
de deux choses l'une où vous êtes pour
l'indépendance et vous allez en tout cas
jusqu'au bout de votre logique avons
quitte à perdre a dit je j'ai perdu mais
on ne fait pas ce qu'il fait là s'est il
franchit le rubicon pour y pêcher à la
ligne
c'est vraiment pas ça aujourd'hui ce
qu'on attend d'un politique est ce que
un gouvernement en exil parce qu'il ya
quand même quatre ministres autour de
lui et est acceptable pour la belgique
si tenté que bâle et v'là les flamands
vont être très content apparemment sur
tout le secrétaire d'état on appelle ça
un secrétaire d'état belge fédéral qui
est en charge des migrations ça
s'appelle comme ça c'était au franken
qui est membre de la nva que le
mouvement autonomiste flamand donc lui a
dit qu'il n'était pas forcément contre
accueillir tranches de bons exactement
adélaïde cas pas si vous disiez
effectivement les français eux il
commence aussi à avoir une opinion un
petit peu distanciée de caen disons que
le regard est plus critique sur les élus
indépendantistes
c'est intéressant c'est que du coup la
problématique elle croit justement ces
deux questions à la fois la question de
l'indépendance des régions et là on voit
dans nos études qualitatives notamment
des français qui sont effectivement
plutôt critique sur la réserve et un
petit peu exaspéré par par ces
mouvements mais ils ont très bien
compris que le débat qui étaient autour
de ça c'est aussi un débat sur la
question de l'europe et la question de
vers quelle europe
on va quel rôle le repas à jouer et du
coup ça nous renvoie six mois en arrière
la séquence électorale on n'a vu qu'une
question de quelle europe est vraiment
centrale autour tout surtout une série
de problématiques qui sont à la fois
national et supranational mais voilà
donc c'est intéressant de voir que les
français eux mêmes ont saisi à nouveau
cette question européenne comme étant au
coeur de ces sujets et pas uniquement un
problème espagnol j'ai une question
peut-être un peu plus anecdotique mais
on le sait plus de manettes un ancien
journaliste
hier il a savait plus où il est et il
est réapparu à bruxelles les partis nous
dit-on maintenant voiture avec donc ses
ministres il ya c'est de la mise en
scène il ya un côté quand même un peu
fuite à varenne on l'a dit cette fois il
n'est pas lui saisit les palissades
cette ferme inra peut-être anambé
général de gaulle non encore une fois ce
qui est énorme il fait de la politique
qui fait de la com il est parce que
c'est toujours les deux comme tout le
monde il n'est pas le seul à faire de la
politique et de la com suivez mon regard
mais simplement mai mais en même temps
il ya quelque chose de très très bizarre
dans cette histoire ce qu'on aimerait
comprendre
est-ce que les catins dans la majorité
je pose la question en euros sont pour
l'indépendance ou pas qu'on le sache
moi j'attendais vraiment à ce qu'il
fasse ce il ya eu ce référendum qu'ils
aient passé
et puis il devait avoir la proclamation
bon et il payé non non je ne fais pas
programmation je suspends j'attends je
vais voir ce qui va se passer et ses
résultats la reprend la main et ses
critiques un très bon jeu enfin en tout
cas la roue il reprend la main et puis
l'autre est effectivement dans un corner
aujourd'hui les cordes est visé qu'est
ce qui va se passer de ce point de vue
là qu'est ce qui reste à plus de mots
sauf si les catalans eux mêmes
est ce que vraiment ils vont tant leur
destin ou pastorales le 25 à 100 % de
participation et un résultat absolument
incroyable de 90% fin voilà donc ce
n'est qu'un référendum stalinien on va
dire et ensuite ce qui est intéressant
c'est quand même le face-à-face
puigdemont
rajoy puisque ça fait des années que ça
dure qu'on sait que depuis 2010 rares
combats en fait les catalans donc il ya
quelque chose qui s'est joué à mon avis
entre les deux hommes et le fait est que
je suis pas sûr que puis de mon sache
vraiment s'il peut continuer le rapport
de force en ayant une majorité derrière
lui donc cesser ce qui montre en se
mettant en scène au niveau européen est
là il trouve une posture comment je
trouve assez esthétique mais je passais
de la communication pas en tout cas
c'est une posture où effectivement il ya
quelque chose de l'ordre du film et qui
montre qu'il est faible en catalogne
moi je pense que c'est comme ça qu'il
faut c'est déjà l'homme cedh à pour but
dans l'effectif donc la fin de
l'histoire le 21 décembre
je pense que les élections du 21
décembre ça a été un super coup droit je
crois que là il a très bien repris la
main et comment se dérober face à une
échéance démocratique pour me le demande
je crois que là on verra ce qui est oui
moi je pense que toute façon ça sera
perdu pour piles demandé nous
interdisons madrid qui continue à
employer la manière forte parce que dès
aujourd'hui alors c'est la cour
constitutionnelle suspendait la
déclaration d'indépendance un mot il
s'est vraiment ils y vont il joue son
jeu jusqu'au bout il a raison il abat
ses cartes et devant l'autre non mais
encore une fois jean pas discuter moi
j'ai très très frappé par sa en dehors
de tout jugement de valeur
puis deux mois et ce qu'il a vraiment
bien joué je crois pas que vous dites
c'est esthétique c'est peut-être
esthétique mais il a mal joué je crois
franchement maintenant se réfugie re
l'europe enfin je veux dire derrière
l'europe derrière le paravent de ski et
l'europe aujourd'hui salut apporté quoi
cela tombe bien le fait qu'on déplace
aussi un questionnement vers l'europe
c'est à dire que après le 21 décembre
on fera aussi face moi je suis pas
d'accord avec vous quand vous dites au
fond l'europe n'a jamais joué ce rôle
peut-être mais si elle veut s'inventer à
l'avenir il serait temps qu'elle essaie
de jouer un rôle plus politique et ça
c'est une question qui est posée à
l'ensemble du catalogue caisse quelques
jours parce qu'ils posaient c'est par
rapport à la décomposition des
états-nations en tout cas aux tensions
qui existent autour des états nations
est-ce qu'on veut porter une europe plus
fédérale ou pas c'est ça la question que
peut jouer avec moi à la tête de la
france alors parmi nos internautes et un
mari qui nous dit qu'elle est tout à
fait d'accord avec andré bercoff raison
de le souligner
c'est pas à bruxelles cette fois ci mais
à strasbourg que ça se passait
aujourd'hui nous y sommes demain 1er
novembre c'est la fin de l'état
d'urgence remplacé par la loi
antiterroriste un texte controversé mais
adopté le 18 octobre que le président de
la république est allé donc défendre
aujourd'hui à strasbourg devant la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme on
regarde emmanuel macron et on en parle
la loi renforçant la sécurité intérieure
et la lutte contre le terrorisme n'a
aucunement pour objet de pérenniser
l'état d'urgence comme certains l'ont
dit mais elle prévoit des mesures
nécessaires à la protection de nos
compatriotes strictement définies
encadré est soumise à un contrôle
renforcé des juges qui nous permet
d'être tout à la fois efficaces dans la
lutte contre le terrorisme et de pouvoir
mettre fin à la procédure d'exception
que nos avions ouverte il ya maintenant
deux ans semak rôle européen là qui va
plaider sa cause à strasbourg
bacon l'européen il a toujours été
européen où il continue patrick
guillemant il continue il persiste et
ici les la raison d'ailleurs de son
point de vue à lui de persister de
signer et puis ce qu'est ce qu'il dit
alors c'est tout le problème
est ce que l'état d'urgence passé dans
le quotidien des lois va sceller
l'avenir qui le dira est-ce que ça va
être beaucoup plus efficace avec la fin
de l'état d'urgence par rapport au
climat qui se passe avec les un certain
nombre de dalles schiste qui parait-il
rentrerait en france c'est l'avenir
c'est le résultat
il a raison d'aller à strasbourg alors
qu'on se fait régulièrement condamnée
par la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme il avait déjà reçu le président
de la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme en juin pour évoquer avec lui
justement les interrogations et puis il
ya beaucoup de juristes français
imminent qui d'intellectuels qui ont dit
qu'ils étaient inquiets face à cette
transcription dans la halle dans la loi
de l'état d'urgence donc je crois qu'il
a tout à fait raison d'avoir été plaidé
sa cause
je sais pas si je rejoindrai ses
arguments je pense que plaider sa cause
c'est une chose c'est faire un discours
après le sujet c'est l'application et on
voit bien qu'il ya d'énormes
interrogations sur la façon dont par
exemple lorsqu'on est assigné à
résidence aujourd'hui les choses sont
efficaces ou pas moi j'ai surtout
regardé le procès meira et quand j'ai vu
comment le directeur régional des
services à toulouse expliqué comment ils
n'avaient pas été entendus pendant des
mois et des mois par la caméra je pense
que le sujet c'est pas la loi je pense
que c'est les pratiques et pour moi
cette question du discours d' emmanuel
macron je la comprends encore une fois
en communication mais je pense que le
sujet c'est comment est ce qu'on va
devenir plus efficace pour repérer en
amont les les potentiels pas une loi
liberticide pour vous ah c'est une loi
tout à fait liberticide mais c'est ce
que je crains surtout qu'elle ne soit
pas efficace
on va parler effectivement vous
l'évoquez du retour des djihadistes on
écoute d'abord le miz de l'intérieur
gérard collomb c'était ce matin sur rtl
ceux qui restent ensuite en liberté sont
évidemment tout suivi par la dgsi donc
de surveiller tout signe à raison n'ont
pas signé à l'arrêt à résidence mais
surveillé race électroniquement la dg
s'ils n'ont pas de bracelet électronique
mais croyez-moi nos services travaillent
de manière importante je fais confiance
à des services que nous avons renforcé
et qui justement nous ont permis de
déjouer les attentats dont vous parliez
tout à l'heure il fait preuve d'une
belle assurance
quand il dit on en a 110 à l'oeil mais
je trouve parce que
une surveillance sans bracelet sans
assignation à résidence ou sans contrôle
judiciaire ce qui est d'ailleurs la loi
on peut pas obliger quelqu'un être un
contrôle judiciaire à pointer à la
gendarmerie s'il n'y a pas eu passage
devant le juge etc
je trouve qu'ils montrent beaucoup
d'assurance quant à la surveillance
la question s'était déjà posée au moment
des attentats on nous expliquait que en
gros pour suivre correctement à
l'individu 24 heures sur 24 il faut à
peu près huit policiers alors c'est à
dire huit policiers par bonhomme mais
c'est à dire que c'est des moyens
considérables
je pense que les gens de la dgsi les
policiers les gendarmes sont des gens
qui font leur travail
je trouve qu'être ministre et dire on
les suit tous c'est quasiment mettre au
défi ceux qui diront bâtir moi je suis
pas suivi et je vais vous faire voir on
le sait adélaïde les les français
approuvent massivement finalement le
texte sur la durée ça peut continuer
enfin voilà ils sont ils ont
définitivement renoncé à une certaine
critique par rapport au liberté
restreinte qu'impose ce texte
oui on sait que lorsqu'on observe depuis
depuis 2015 les premières mesures qui
ont été prises après les premiers
attentats
on sent que sur ce sujet en particulier
les françaises sont sont assez dures et
est assez pragmatique et du coup c'est
vrai qu'ils acceptent des textes peut
être apparaître assez liberticide et
voilà ils voient en vous dit
effectivement ils ont le tec
l'efficacité plutôt que ça que le texte
dans sa globalité passe très bien et les
mesures une paru ne sont vraiment très
majoritairement soutenu et quand ledit
majoritairement par le taux de 80%
notamment sur voile a assigné à
résidence
déjà 10 client serveur n est pas a
priori déjà les contrôles d'identité les
choses qui peuvent être directement ou
est encore que la voile à l'approbation
peut-être plus faibles sur ces sujets là
mais elle reste largement bkc oui assez
favorable pour les contrôler les zones
où il ya des événements particuliers
vous savez je pense qu'il ya un lien
entre les deux sujets catalogne est
sorti de l'état d'urgence c'est
l'affaiblissement des états aujourd'hui
en france l'état un champ d'action
beaucoup plus réduit qu'auparavant ils
moins il est moins présent dans
l'économie il peu moins influé sur
l'économie et sur le chômage on voit
bien qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas l'état qui
décide c'est pas la politique
gouvernementale qui décide de faire
baisser le chômage donc l'état ne bat
plus monnaie comme précédemment dans
qu'est ce qui reste au niveau du
régalien c'est la sécurité donc d'une
certaine façon l'état le gouvernement
ont une obligation de résultat une
obligation d'agir et de toute façon une
obligation de réagir et de dire des
choses
en gros il reste plus beaucoup de levier
puissant aujourd'hui aux états européens
si on voit qu'ils ont déjà perdu une
bonne partie de la marge économique
ils ont perdu de la marge ils ont perdu
en marge de manoeuvre budgétaire il
reste la sécurité
donc il leur faut agir quitte à faire du
déclaratif encore une fois quand on aime
on l'a vu avec gérard collomb tout à
l'heure il y en a tant déçu j'ai très
très concret parce que celui des
familles de djihadistes qui sont en
passe de rentrer en france des sujets
c'est un défi absolument yard est
rarement hélas qu'est-ce qu'on fait
attendre et d'abord je pourrais revenir
suggère coulon qui effectivement le sur
l'assurance fait plaisir à voir enfin on
aimerait bien être aussi rassuré que lui
qui n'était pas moi je voudrais juste
une lyre 2
à propos de liberticide je pense qu'on
appela un tout petit peu à tort et à
travers
je pense qu'il ya liberticide mais aussi
super ici d'
c'est à dire que la liberté sans la vie
c'est pas de la liberté la liberté quand
on sait que n'importe qui peut être pour
des raisons x et y ai gardé égorgé sur
une gare comme à saint charles ou à
saint-etienne du rouvray ou par un
camion soit disant fouet nice je vais
pas citer tous un tout ce qui s'est
passé depuis deux ans faut quand même
pas l'oublier même si nous il se passe
quelque chose il y à une idéologie
totalitaire qui consiste à dire qu'il ya
des gens loin d'être une majorité et une
minorité qui viennent là pour
effectivement détruire et tuer qui sont
là pour ça le problème
il n'est pas de savoir si c'est la loi
est ce que vraiment ils font tout pour
ça vous parlez des gens qui sont
assignés à résidence ou pas vous avez
entendu parler d'eux olivier corel près
de montpellier
cette personne là dont on sait qu'il a
conseillé le mentor le menteur et merahi
l'hemera des pâtes coulibaly mais des
frères les frères soit chez compagnie
cette personne-là reçoit qui elle veut
est corde elle veut elle est en liberté
peut-être surveiller mais franchement
très peu surveillés
monsieur vers problème un état monsieur
baroin alors monsieur faire que vous
avez raison de rappeler les drames de
saint-charles de saint-etienne du
rouvray et loulou d'être tennis qui se
sont produits sous état d'urgence
précisément ils se sont produits sous
état d'urgence état d'urgence donc ce
qui veut bien dire que les l'idée même
d'état d'urgence
effectivement il fallait la réponse
sécuritaire est aussi politique le 13
novembre en matière d'état d'urgence il
ya eu 4600 perquisition sous état
d'urgence depuis le 13 novembre
80% de ces perquisitions ont eu lieu
dans les trois mois qui ont suivi parce
qu'il fallait mettre une espèce de deux
coups de pression de coup de massue de
coup de karcher pour reprendre une
expression
célèbre ensuite la question sur sécurité
versus liberté c est ce que l'état
d'urgence est ce que les nouvelles
mesures sont garanties de sécurité il
n'y a pas de risque zéro
nous sommes d'accord mais si je faisais
pas le problème j'observe qu'en fait on
a tendance à opposer la question
liberticide la question efficacité
moi je pense que c'est un faux débat
c'est à dire que je pense que c'est pas
parce qu'on prend des textes qui sont
extrêmement durs et effectivement
restreignent les libertés
on va être plus efficace en fait je
pense qu'il faut voir les choses comme
ça par rapport à ce que vous disiez sur
le fait que les français sont
extrêmement durs et apprendre à 80% le
fait de durcir la loi parce que les
français aspirent à l'efficacité c'est
pas parce qu'ils regardent élise la loi
c'est parce qu'ils se disent on sera
mieux protégé de cette manière est donc
le sujet moi je suis effectivement très
préoccupé par ce qui se passe au procès
meira parce que je trouve que les
révélations qui sont faites sont
extrêmement intéressante sur la manière
dont finalement entre les services on
n'écoute pas d'abord le directeur des
services de toulouse ont dit on dit à
maera n'est pas n'est pas vraiment
dangereux on va pouvoir l'utiliser comme
indicateur moi je trouve qu'il ya quand
même un problème c'est à dire que moi
gérard collomb quand je les écoute
expliqué tout est sous contrôle ça
m'inquiète et je suis d'accord avec ce
que vous venez dire il ya une forme de
provocation à dire ne vous inquiétez pas
tout est sous contrôle parce que comme
tout et aujourd'hui affaire de
communication etc
on peut dire que tout ça est repéré et
pourrait conduire à des actes qui
peuvent être des actes héroïques à des
aides fiscales à 6 puis après j'ai une
question comme tous les français
sinon ils sont favorables à une
une action sécuritaire efficace mais pas
uniquement ils ont pour eux la sécurité
c'est la base
mais sur la question de la lutte
antiterroriste est un sujet majeur qui
est en gros comment secours s'attaquent
aux racines du mal et ça passe par
d'autres choses auxquelles sont
pragmatiques
c'est non mais c'est lutter contre le
djihadisme à ses racines qu'est-ce que
ça passe par l'éducation à l'école les
prisons c'est à dire si on était prêts
avant maintenant des mesures avril
celui qui veut répond quand la ministre
des armées florence parly dit s'il y en
a qui sanctuaire ak c'est tant mieux
la raison je vois vraiment pas pourquoi
on aurait de la tendresse envers des
gens qui sont partis et d'abord la
question qui sont partis aussi pour tuer
comme disait la mère de mohamed merah
pas au procès moi je suis très heureux
de mon fils est fier il a mis la france
à genoux
à partir du moment où les gens qui
considèrent que il leur ennemi d'abord
c'est la france par exemple et que
vraiment ce sont ces l'intelligence avec
l'ennemi
je sais pas moi je vous demande pas
rétablissement de la peine de mort ou
quoi que ce soit je demande de sa voix
arrive c'est quand vous dites les
français sont durs pas les français sont
deux ils ont peur selon claire c'est pas
ils sont durs ils ont peur alors est ce
qu'on peut leur en vouloir d'avoir peur
quand il voit qu une sharon ou au
bataclan et c'est n'importe qui c'est
plus seulement des juifs ou des
caricaturiste de charlie hebdo
n'importe qui peut être l'objet de même
si c'est encore heureusement
heureusement pas deux pas des milliers
mais des centaines comment voulez vous
que les gens se disent mais comment le
l'état où le savait depuis longtemps a
le monopole de la violence pourquoi pour
protéger les citoyens
c'est l'état ne protège plus les
citoyens ont le ou les sens que les
citoyens ne se sentent pas protégés
c'est là où il ya un problème puisque
pour terminer juste à côté c'est parce
que la fermera une mini-polémique nicole
belloubet garde des sceaux n'était pas
sûr
image de la signature de la loi
antiterroriste il y avait le ministre
l'intérieur gérard collomb christophe
castaner porte parole également le
prétendait public mais pas le garde des
sceaux ce dont certains se sont étonnés
en disant c'est quand même une loi que
possède la justice voit la vraie
question c'est je pense que une fois
deux fois trois fois ça va les
signatures scénario à l'américaine sous
les caméras avec ça je pense que c'est
le meilleur voilà c'est bon alors un
sujet qui occupe la droite maintenant
les exclusions en principe entériner ce
soir c'est le nouveau feuilleton qui a
agité les républicains mais maintenant
il y en a un autre c'est le débat sur le
débat
laurent wauquiez le favori veut un débat
seul devant les rues les seuls militants
ses challengers florence portelli et
maël de calan réclamé un débat télévisé
animé par des journalistes
finalement freiner de cette élection à
la présidence des républicains qui
semblait un très confortable pour le
révoquer n'est peut-être pas si facile
que ça ne se présente pas sous les
meilleurs auspices
je sais pas si elle se présente bien ou
mal d'abord je crois que c'est très
difficile d'avoir un quelconque sondage
d'opinion sur un noyau d'adhérents par
la spécialiste mais je crois que c'est
très difficile d'avoir une un
échantillon non je pense que laurent
wauquiez en réalité son souci c'est pas
de faire un débat sur un plateau dans un
théâtre devant des militants devant les
français la question c'est qu'il veut
pas de questions de journalistes parce
que dans une campagne interne
même s'il ya des lignes différentes qui
s'expriment des personnalités
différentes qui s'expriment on veut pas
appuyer là où ça fait trop mal c'est
quand même des gens du même parti s'il
ya des journalistes forcément les
journalistes se poseront les questions
gênantes et quand il ya un favori
quand il ya un favori aussi clivant que
laurent wauquiez qui a des formules
quand même assez choc
1 ce week-end un favori qui cherchent
comme l'expliqué guillaume tabard dans
le figaro d'abord à cliver avançant à
rationner de proposer de rassembler
il a il a tout à perdre face à face à
des journalistes donc je ne sais pas si
l'élection se présente bien au mal pour
lui
moi j'ai le sentiment qu'il est dansé
dansé rails dans son chemin après je
pense que laurent wauquiez emploi des
mots des mots forts ils reprochent
emmanuel macron de diviser la france
d'opposer les français mais quand lui a
fait deux parisiens sont injures
favorite
là je trouve qu'il ya un souci il fait
la même chose qui est manuel ânes de la
province de la province reprocher
parlant tout ce qui est excessif est
insignifiant et puis la macro n'a pas de
coeur ou maquereau n'a pas d'armé enfin
bon ça c'est non moi moi ce qui m'amuse
là dedans c'est que je trouve que par
rapport à aux républicains puis-je
demandons aux parler est un monstre de
fanatisme et d'autoritarisme gère quant
aux voies ou un sont des républicains
quand même incapable de faire un quorum
pour exclure des gens nommés faut
revenir à ça quand même
le spectacle qu'il donne depuis les
primaires d'ailleurs qui ont été pour
une catastrophe une métastase
cancérigène de première grandeur les
primaires étaient faits pour les
républicains quand même vomi d'état
manoir pour le pape françois ça n'avait
pas de sens
on a vu ce qui s'est passé et qu'est ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui ils continuent
à se déchirer sur savoir comment on va
discuter c'est extraordinaire c'est à
dire le spectacle quand même d'un parti
est un parti de gouvernement comme les
socialistes d'ailleurs de notre côté
c'est en termitière qui est en train de
se décomposer sous nos yeux
quel que soit ce qui va se passer vos
qui va probablement gagner
on n'en sait rien mais on va voir mais
moi ça me ce qui me fascine c'est le
spectacle qu'ils mettent qu'il mette la
mise en scène de leur décomposition
adélaïde à ce sujet est ce que
finalement la jeune génération c'est pas
comme ce qui s'est passé dans d'autres
la jeune génération représentée par maël
de 41 ans n'a pas envie de servir que de
faire valoir dans cette élection c'est
un peu pour ça d'ailleurs que sont
favorables un débat télévisé parce que
vos doigts effectivement la question de
ce que pourrait être ce que les
journalistes pour mettre en difficulté
laurent wauquiez se faire connaître
voilà je pense que voilà pour lui
l'enjeu enfin le pour elle le sujet
c'est qu'il est le plus connu plus
identifiées donc quelque part je dis pas
que ça va assurer son élection mais ça
contribue en tout cas le
à le rendre crédible et légitime alors
que pour mail de calan florence portelli
un enjeu de visibilité de se faire
connaître et de hêtres préparer la suite
isme ans qui sont aussi conscients de la
difficulté pour cette élection là mais
du coup il ya sept ans je l'aï c'est
aussi pour ça que laurent wauquiez pas
favorable à un débat télévisé
et l'autre chose c'est qu'effectivement
c'est compliqué de faire des enquêtes
auprès d'adhérents nos militants donc on
sait pas exactement comment l'élection
se présentent en revanche dans les
études qualitatives mon ami même une
communauté citoyenne et on voit comment
réagissent les sympathisants ont parlé
sympathisants mais deux
lr ils sont quand même sur une ligne
assez ok j'en viens dire ouais assez
ferme il faut revenir à il faut revenir
aux fondamentaux c'est laurent wauquiez
qui est interne ses fondamentaux ce qui
était amusant d'ailleurs ce qu'ils
disent il a toujours été fidèle au
triton identité ils ont oublié comme ces
voix là c'est sûr pitié on va parler on
va on va parler de jeu vous propose
juste d'écouter parce que ça s'enchaîne
bien avec ce que vous dites on va
écouter amélie de montchanin qui était
l'invité du talk du figaro hier les qui
ferait à un million chalain qui est
député la république en marche de
l'essonne c'est un parti qui est en
train de se en tout cas donné
l'impression de se refermer d'être en
train de se replier sur des peurs de
plus être du tout ni humaniste on y
réformisme vraiment européen amélie de
montchanin je le précise qui a travaillé
avec alain juppé ou avant de rejoindre
emmanuel macron et valérie pécresse
lucile schmid je comprends pas que
laurent wauquiez veulent pas d'un débat
télévisé parce que quand on veut se
mesurer à manuel macron c'est un peu ce
qui fait dans le journal du dimanche de
ce week-end on peut pas refuser des
débats télévisés donc je comprends pas
je pense que il n'a pas du tout
conscience de ses intérêts en plus je
pense que c'est quelqu'un qui peut être
un bon débatteur donc je comprends pas
je pense c'est une sorte de refus
d'obstacle et par rapport à ce que vous
disiez sur les jeunes pourront
évidemment c'est bien bon après je pense
que le sujet c'est que moi je pense que
vous qui va gagner enfin ça me semble
acquis il faut quand même le dire
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il est il est de
loin sans doute le meilleur chef des
républicains qui va être potentiellement
donc en revanche je ne comprends pas
leur attitude vis-à-vis dé constructif
c'est à dire que les constructifs ils
sont eux-mêmes en difficulté n'ont pas
de ligne sauf de koléa macron et ils en
font ils en font quelque chose
d'important comme un bout de sparadrap
du capitaine haddock
donc moi je trouve que laurent wauquiez
là il a une espèce d'inhibition pas ce
qu'il va devenir chef du parti mais il
faut évidemment qu'il fasse un débat
télévisé il faut qu'il y ait non pas
qu'ils excluent les constructif la vidéo
qu'il avoue qu'elle permettait de s'en
séparer très bien ce qu'est le sujet
c'est plutôt de reconnaître qu'ils sont
déjà partis enfin vous savez les
exclusions
aujourd'hui quand les parties exclu
c'est un aveu de faiblesse donc faire un
feuilleton d'exclusion c'est un double
aveu de faiblesse
quand le ps voulait exclure des gens moi
je
vécue parce que j'ai été au parti
socialiste j'étais parti de longue date
si l'on essayait de m'exclure mais
j'étais parti donc le sujet c'est qu'on
exclut plus personne dans les partis
aujourd'hui on est déjà parti et on
reconnaît qu il sont partis c'est tout
et puis on leur souhaite bon vent et
puis on fait sa ligne politique et puis
on fait un débat à la télévision
j'aurais reviens à l'instant écoutez moi
ça va vite
c'était dans votre ville c'était dans
votre question marie amélie et c'était
dans votre réponse sur la jeune
génération la oumma kron avait fait un
mal terrible c'est que wauquiez il n'a
que 42 ans il est né en 1975 c'est un
très bon cru il fait déjà vu et du coup
c'est des gens né en 1978 qui passe pour
la jeune génération est celle insultes
macron a fait un mal terrible à la
droite c'est qu'aujourd'hui baroin à 50
51 ans
c'est un vieux bruno le maire alors
bruno le maire il est passé au
gouvernement mais ça y est et on a
l'impression qu'il a pris les seniors de
45 ml manche en a quand même bien
d'écouter elle a juste fait pas son âge
et elle est l'exemple un des exemples de
cette jeune génération qui a émergé
vraiment ça ça fait mal au dessus des 85
le vrai problème mais vous me le dire ou
même et vous avez dit le parti
socialiste essaie de m'exclure mais au
jeu j'étais parti bien avant mais ce
qu'on ne comprend pas essayez là ça
augmente le mal si on le comprend après
quand on résume en termes d'idh
hypermarchés ou de ou de petites
boutiques
c'est que au fond les constructif
ils sont partis depuis longtemps ils
sont partis ils sont avec macron bon
soft sauf qu'ils n'ont pas rejoint la
ligne en marche qui devrait lui faire
nous sommes d'accord avec tout ce que
dit macron edouard philippe n'en
parlerons pas etc
nous sommes pourquoi n'ont ils pas dit
on et lrm et on est d'accord pourquoi
parce que justement il faut aller
jusqu'à la boue de la destruction du
parti républicain et donc regarder des
pour le boutique appelons le lieu
appelons le comme vous voulez pour
justement accentuée et ferrer la
division ces salles tout compte sur nous
ils seraient partis depuis longtemps
adélaïde juste les attaques de laurent
wauquiez contre mâcon on a déjà en
mesure ce que ça peu
donner dans l'opinion la société aesc
andré bercoff rappelé tout à l'heure ses
propos sur la haine de la province sur
le dévers de l'âme
je pense tout bas je pense que ça a
nourri simplement le ras le bol des
français la défiance envers la politique
voilà ben c'est de la politique
politicienne
voilà c'est des critiques un peu facile
et les postures l'un et l'autre dans la
posture donc je suis pas sûr que ce soit
médecin bénéfique ni points comme pour
l'autre en revanche que ce que je
voulais dire c'est que la question de la
place des constructive versus lll pose
la question de la foi de la ligne sur
laquelle doit se reconstruire et l'air
et de l'espace politique
aujourd'hui il est constructif je pense
que s'ils n'ont pas rejoint la
république en marché qui se disent que
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron magne
politique plutôt identifiés ou un
qualifié de droite ou libérale mais on
sent bien que parce que son électorat de
départ il faut quand même rappeler que
60% de son électorat au premier tour ce
sont des sympathisants ps
il va devoir un moment ou un autre
mettre la barre plus à gauche donc du
coup ça va peut-être libéré un espace
sur sa droite
est-ce que cet espace là l air sera en
mesure de le combler avec laurent
wauquiez à la tête de l air ou est ce
qu'il ya un espace justement pour une
ligne de droite pu noter modéré à la
jupe est enfin allé constructif qui
pourront jouer un petit peu il va peut
être les garde-fous du gouvernement donc
je pense que trancher de manière aussi
radicale maintenant c'est un peu
prématuré je vois pas comment un edouard
philippe qui est chef du gouvernement
sur rfo un garde-fou du gouvernement je
comprends pas je pense plutôt au groupe
mais après on parlait de constructif je
veux dire edouard philippe
heller gérald darmanin lr bruno le maire
et l'air est aujourd'hui mal de ceux qui
sont aussi à l'extérieur des salaires et
par thierry solère finir par devenir
ministre du gouvernement il est le sois
moi je moi je pense que la fin des
années il est ridicule
je pense qu'il ya une partie de son
effectif qui sont ridicules en fait
c'est à dire qu'on a l'impression qu'ils
ont pris ce petit label parce qu'ils se
disent que ça va s'élargir mais je suis
d'accord avec andré bercoff à quelqu'un
comme tirer solaire il devrait être à la
république en marche seul après du côté
des centristes c'est un petit peu plus
compliqué parce que évidemment ils
aspirent à créer un truc de centre-droit
mais la vérité c'est que les constructif
sont déjà clivé en plusieurs cours
oui vous est intarissable sur ses
poursuivants si vous le voulez bien les
états unis l'équipe de donald trump
s'est-elle concerter avec moscou pour
influer sur l'injection
c'est la question au coeur de l'enquète
enquête qui s'est accélérée hier avec la
mise en accusation de trois membres de
l'équipe de campagne du président
américain
l'un d'eux a même reconnu avoir menti au
fbi alors qui dit vrai qui dit faux
question et sujet pour vous andré
bercoff cette fois ça va être difficile
pour trame de s'en sortir
vous savez c'est très simple trame
depuis novembre on le pense quelque
chose sont du pitch plaintes se fait un
nom
c'est dur et d'ailleurs il n'aurait
jamais dû être président etc etc je veux
pas rappeler des souvenirs personnels
mais quand même car je suis de
l'interviewer en 2016 je me rappelle
aussi bien aux états unis chez mes
copains journaliste new-yorkais que ici
chez mes copains journalistes de paris d
et publie ton interview très vite parce
que dans un mois on n'entend plus parler
de trappes
c'était bien avant la demie niçois
républicaine je vous assure j'ai eu mais
on m'a dit que ça comme on me disait
évidemment que françois hollande allait
se représenter de façon absolue c'est
amusant de voir ça non je lis je crois
qu'il ya quelque chose c'est clair que
il y a les trois cadets république à je
parle de l'establishment et les
démocrates qui ne voulait pas d'autres
c'est clair bon après il s'est passé ce
qui s'est passé il se passe
pour revenir à votre question line big
band c'est très très long alors est-ce
que effectivement approuvé la la gérance
russe il a supposé agences russes dans
l'élection de trump va être trouvée elle
ne l'est pas encore on va le voir
effectivement il y a muller qui
enquêtent il y avait il ya ça mais ça va
être un processus très long et surtout
il faut appeler c'est ça qui est amusant
et why américains c'est que le
washington post
il peut pas être soupçonné de 36 mhz et
exagéré c'est vraiment le contraire a
publié la fameux le fameux rapport qui
que hillary clinton aurait commandé
financé avec le parti démocrate
une enquête effectivement visant à
déstabiliser trup avec les russes alors
qu'ils vous
tout ça c'est ce qui est c'est ça qui
est remarquable
au-delà du cas trump du cas d'une
éventuelle intervention russe en sous
main etc
moi ce que je trouve assez remarquable
dans cette histoire d'abord c'est
l'indépendance et la rapidité de la
justice américaine en france les
procédures sont longues on sait que
c'est pas forcément facile pour les
juges de mener d instruction c'est pas
le même souhait c'est pas le même
système
le travail de la presse effectivement le
washington le washington post qui est un
journal pour faire simple plutôt
démocrate centre gauche n'a pas peur de
sortir le dossier qui va peut-être
empoisonné hillary clinton parce qu'il
faut se dire que l'information passe
avant tout et je trouve qu'en la matière
quand on voit cette capacité à la presse
sérieuse qu'à la presse sérieuse de
travailler et cette diligence qu'est la
justice américaine pour travailler les
démos que les états unis restent une
grande démocratie
sur ce point là alors on imagine à
moscou le sujet est suivi avec intérêt
sergueï lavrov le ministre russe des
affaires étrangères
évidemment démenti toute ingérence russe
dans cette affaire on écoute distraite
six pixels le procureur ni idiot nouveau
fucked avait mené les camps script au
litige serait cool tous les outils qui
était presque normale norme gsm et en
beauté marie maurice schérer fac nos
bras burkhalter que la qualité le design
stonewall à new york en dhr et si beau
spectacle aux pro gbagbo sont au
marathon les risques pour eux jusqu'à
présent aujourd'hui encore une fois à
l'heure où on parle il n'y a pas encore
un fait avéré
c'est un problème c'est que ce qu'ils
disent un million les russes se
défendent en disant j'en sais rien tous
les russes ondes
le problème c est ce que vraiment les
russes ont influencé 160 millions
d'américains mais le problème c'est que
on a dit li hao départ cette
illégitimité de trump dans une partie en
tout cas des élites américaines et de la
population mais enfin une partie de la
population et je trouve que ça va
aujourd'hui très loin parce que si
effectivement le washington post qui en
fou de joie et un journal plutôt de
centre gauche vous lui disiez très
justement
et si ces deux enquêtes se contredisent
qui va payer les pots cassés je prouve
en tout cas une chose que juste je
voudrais c'est que ils vont pas oublier
l'économie
aujourd'hui quand même les jobs
reviennent amérique la croissance est
plutôt bonne
c'est là sa c30 qui s'étend du terme de
novembre prochain
très sincèrement c'est pas sérieux c'est
l'agent ce que ça va jouer ça va jouer
sur les élections par rapport à
l'économie et ce economy stupid ça reste
véritablement le mot touareg
alors je me tourne vers valentin pilate
qui nous a rejoints
valentin qui suit les réseaux sociaux
pour pour le figaro avant de vous donner
la parole valentin je rappelle juste les
résultats la question du jour posée par
le figaro à ses internautes
la faire de l'ingérence russe peut-elle
entraver la présidence de trump est pour
le moment nos internautes répondent à
60%
oui sinon il se dit quoi sur les réseaux
sur secteur
alors sur les réseaux si on regarde
depuis ce matin on observe en fait de
tendance pour beaucoup en fait
l'internaute c'est du trump bashing ce
qui se passe et pour d'autres en fait
c'est tout simplement une justice et une
démocratie exemplaire
donc pour celles et ceux qui s'agace de
cette justice américaine on à louis qui
nous dit sur le site internet du figaro
le système et ses représentants n'ont
toujours pas digéré l'élection de trump
il faut dire que ce sont des démocrates
comme il est dit dans son commentaire
mention spéciale à hillary clinton pour
nathalie le fbi et la justice ne semble
s'être intéressé à cette affaire que
dans la mesure où la courte
collaboration entre mana fort et donald
trump permettrait en fait d'éclabousser
le président américain on a bernard qui
s'attaque directement à hillary clinton
et si la justice américaine
s'intéressait vraiment au mensonge
d'hillary clinton
et en face on à louis qui se réjouit
donc de cette justice et demande même
s'il pouvait être possible qu en europe
de telles investigations puisse avoir
lieu et fouillé même donc du coup dans
les milieux du pouvoir
il faut savoir en fait que les géants de
la tech comme twitter google et facebook
on y reviendra après avec mr et avec
marie amélie mais ils sont vraiment dans
la ligne 2
mir du congrès américains qui enquêtent
sur de possibles ingérences de moscou
dans la campagne qui aurait mené et du
coup qui aurait mené à la victoire de
donald trump
ces géants de la tech en fait sont
accusés d'avoir servi de plate-forme
pour de la manipulation politique venant
de la russie facebook estime que ce sont
126 millions d'américains soit un
habitant sur trois qui a pu être exposés
aux fêtes news supposément envoyés
depuis la russie de plus selon bhl ou
moins bloomberg facebook souhaiterait
embaucher des salariés à créditer secret
défense pour lutter contre ce fléau
donc en fait vraiment une cellule
vraiment purement dédiés à ça il leur
suffirait d'avoir des bons journalistes
juste effectivement on en parle d'autant
plus qu'aujourd'hui le congrès
auditionne des représentants des gaffes
à google facebook sur ce sujet vous
vouliez ajouté un an je vais dire une
chose rapidement parce qu'on arrive pas
d'accord c'est que quand papadopoulos
reconnaît qu il a menti au fbi aille je
pensais que ça pader losc est donc
acquis était le conseiller affaires
étrangères de trump dans sa lutte
interne est vraiment dans une série
genre mind hunter c'est à dire qu'on est
dans une série netflix littéralement et
cette démocratie elle est très
intéressante parce que quelque part
la morale est toujours présente moi je
prends moi je fonçais assez passionnant
et la deuxième chose que je voulais dire
c'est que n'oublions pas quand même qu'à
mon avis la gérance russell est avérée
elle est avérée aussi dans l'élection de
macron il ya eu des attaques donc la
question c'est aussi de s'interroger sur
ce que veulent les russes c'est cette
question la déstabilisation par rapport
à l'occident moi je pense que c'est un
sujet essentiel franchement sous le
ciseau et je les reprendrai je vais
juste me disant une troisième chose
c'est que on nous avait dit ça ya 30 pt
lui on azadi le break si tu savais c'est
fait et on arrive dans des démocraties
très instable c'est à dire qu' il ya des
résultats qui quelque part peuvent être
remis en cause
et ça c'est très intéressant parce que
il y appellera peut-être lynch me tuera
peut-être un contre au référendum sur le
break site moi je trouve que ces
questions d'instabilité de ces résultats
qui eux-mêmes a été surprenant est
quelque chose qui doit nous amener à
nous interroger sur comment la
démocratie fonctionne juste quand même
gravissime parce qu'il ya aussi des
forces qui pas qu'ils s'attaquent à
déstabiliser les pouvoirs qui a su si
bien sûr je mets
instabilité qui est extrême adelheid un
dernier point sur je mets juste dire un
petit mot sur des faits news est sûre ce
qu'a dit météo sur l'importance d'avoir
une presse de qualité parce que ça
paraît sapin on a vu qu'il y avait chez
ces publicités les chiffres on parle de
millions de lecteurs exposés nous on a
travaillé pendant la campagne sur le sud
est et news en en faisant des enquêtes
parallèles où on exposait des gens à des
faits que nous et après on avait un
échantillon à qui on donnait un démenti
et à notre échantillon avec qui
n'apportait pas le démenti est on
s'apercevrait que même chez les
personnes à qui on dit attention c'était
une technique
ça a laissé des traces profondes en
terme d'image en termes d'intentions de
vote et donc c'est un vrai sujet et d'où
l'intérêt effectivement d'avoir voilà on
va juste à vous regarder à l'écran les
tweets de donald trump sûr qu'il a dû
posté hier sur cette question ils vont
s'afficher
voilà c'est pas de la fédé fait que new
ça c'est son site officiel et il le dit
désolé bottes et 6 heures je fais la
traduction simultanée
oui si on sait qu'ils regrettent qu'on
s'intéresse pas oui pour le mandat porte
du banc comme à caen paraît que témoin
et pourquoi vous intéressait pas focus à
7 est ce qu il advient beliet et merci
beaucoup à vous tous merci à charles
darche qui a été aux manettes de cette
émission brillamment demain c'est la
toussaint mais on se retrouve jeudi pour
un nouveau point de vue est resté sur
figaro live on
on va vous présenter un focus un focus
sur l'exposition rubens qui est
actuellement au musée du luxembourg qui
s'intitule portrait princier et je vous
recommande les explications d'isabelle
schmidt qui sont présentés par yann le
coeur à très bientôt
merci
[Musique]